でも五識によるんです
外とはそれほど関係ないんだけどね
それで何心でしたっけ？サンティーラニチッタ
水道心が生まれる 次に
次に八番目で確定心が生まれる
そこら辺で自動的に何とか決めてしまうんですね
いわゆる目に触れたならば
自動的に眼識が生まれるし
眼識が生まれちゃったら
その心の影響で水道心が生まれる
決めること  あんまりはっきり決めませんだけど
大体好きなものか悪いものかという単純な判断なんですね
それはまたほとんどもうどうしようもない
もうコンピューターと同じく
もう１か０かどっちかにするしかないんだから
で 見たものはいいものか悪いものかという単純なすごいきめ細かい判断が
判断の心が生まれる そこでそこを分けたならば
次の心でもう確定しちゃうんですね
その道ある 確定心が生まれる
で 確定心が生まれたところで
それは八番目のセツナですね
それから人間の感情の心が走っちゃうんですね
同じ心 九番目から 七回ですね
七回同じ心が生まれちゃうんです
それは即行心というんですね
走る心 悪く それも人間にコントロール結構できないものなんです
一旦決めた方向へ心が走ってしまう
同じ心が七回生まれる
それはその即行心はかなり問題で
で この八十九種類の心の中で即行の働きはする心は何でしょうかと見ると
ほとんど善心か不善心ですね
十二種類の不善心 それから八種類の善心
あるいは大心 どっちかなんです
いわゆる善と悪と分けられるんです
例えば見たものは大変好きなものだったら
普通の人にはもう何のことなく
十二不善心の欲瞋恨恨心の八の中の一つ
どっちか生まれてしまうんですね
それで不善心が生まれたことになっちゃう
それで悪い結果がいつか生まれる
もし見たものはものすごい嫌なものだと判断したならば
瞋恨心二つありますね
怒りの心 その二つのひとつが即行の働きしてしまっちゃうんです
大体そういうのはものすごい速さで自動的に瞬時に起こるもんだから
人間にはどうしようもない
決してコントロールできない
嫌な音を聞いたら嫌でないと感じいることはね
相当訓練しなきゃできないんです
一番わかりやすいのは食べ物でしょうね
自分が食べたくない食べ物
ああ これはすごい美味しいやと感動するためには
かなりの訓練しなきゃできないでしょうに
自分がもう目がないほど美味しい食べ物があって
それは嫌ですよ 食べたくないですよという感情を作るためには
かなりの修行は必要でする
ですから 結局プログラムはすでに組み立てられているんです
自然法則で そういうことでもう修行というものはいつでも必要ですよ
怒りっぽい人はどうしようもない
怒りっぽい いつでも落ち込む人はもうどうしようもない
もう落ち込むことしか頭にないんです
何をしても落ち込むと
何も面白いことないと言って落ち込んじゃうでしょう
それですごい面白いことを教えたら
そんなことをやったって結局疲れるだけでまた落ち込んじゃう
強引に激しい刺激なんか与えちゃったら
それ終わった途端ものすごい落ち込んじゃう
あまりにも激しいことをしたんだから
本当に嫌ですよと だから落ち込む人は落ち込むばっかりで
怒る人は怒るばっかりで
でもそういう風にもう性格はもうどうしようもない
そういうことだから 長い間心をもういろんな訓練して育てるということは必ず必要ですね
そのことをもう科学的に説明しようと
そのシステムを ですから
それは仏教の大学の専門家ではなくて
本当に仏教をやっているこの大雄さんみたいに
そういう専門家のための勉強なんですね
ただの信仰じゃないんだと
この教えは 厳密に科学的に整理していて
そういうのは全部理解して指導するんですね
ですから 修行する人にとっては
そんな即行心なんだろうかとか
どうにぜいらなくなっても別にどうったことないんです
修行さえすればそれなりに心は変わっていきます
でも 教える人は人の心を見てちゃんと判断して
その人の性格を見て 性格の強烈さやら弱さやら全部見てね
例えば怒り性格であろうとの怒りの強烈な人はなかなか治りにくい
怒りが弱い人はまあ治りやすいとこそこもありますし
そこで怒りは強烈に何でもパーッと怒りを取る人にとっては
それなりの大胆なショックトリートメントで心を直してあげなくちゃいけないし
で そんなに激しく感情的じゃない人の場合は
それなりに柔らかい方法を決めて修行させなくちゃいけないし
そういうのはまあ指導する側の仕事ですからね
医学はお医者さんだけ知っていればいいでしょうに
手術のやり方とかね 細胞の働きとか
まあそういうのはもう医者が知っていればそれで十分です
我々は治療を受けてもらうと
ある病気に対して治療を受けようと思ったところで
その病気に対してプロ並みの知識を得るということ
その前に死んじゃいますからね
人が 治療を受ける同時に
まあその先生と同じレベルのプロ級の医学知識を得るそうと思って
それ意味がないんです
まあそれで即行心の働きは
そういう善悪か悪か その善行為
悪行為の心なんですね
それでもうカルマも行って終わっちゃうんですね
それで我々知っていたんだというのは
この即行心なんです ああ
知りましたよと あれはバラの花でしたよと
決めるのは即行心なんです
その決めても その時は
これはセツナの順番で言えば九番目と十番目と
それから十五番目までですね
だから見た対象は 年に数えて見ちゃうと
九歳から十四 十五歳までの間は見ているんだということで
十六歳 十七歳で死んじゃいますから
そこはまた見てないんです
そこでこのもう一つ このジャラナという心が七つ同じ心が回転する
そこのカラクリっていうのは
この確定心 起こるでしょ
決めちゃったと 決めた瞬間で
もう決めた心でずっと七回生まれ変わっちゃいますけど
心が プロセス この見たものとはもうほとんど関係ないんですね
勝手なんですね 自分で確定しちゃったら
その考え方でいってしまっちゃうんです
だから見たものが本当は一歳で生まれて
どんどん大きくなって
五歳の人に見られて それから十七歳で死んじゃうでしょうに
その変化過程はさっぱり見る人にとっては関係ないでしょ
それ見る時わかるでしょうに
見る人にとっては そんな見る対象の変化過程はもう興味なしと
自分の目に触れて目が覚めて
あ 決めた それで同じ心でいっちゃって
あ 終わったと 見たんだと
それで見たという実感が生まれて
そこで威張っちゃうんです
見たものの変化過程はもう構いなしと
実際の我々の生き方はそういう生き方なんです
それ瞬間の働きなんですけど
それわからないと思ったら
我々瞬間ではなくて 我々の大雑把な人生の働きを見てください
例えばある人に会ったと
会った瞬間でもう嫌な人だと感じがパッと浮かんだと
何の理屈もないんです
それであいつは嫌な人やと
もう決めて終わってるでしょうに
そこで二度と見ても 三度目見たっても
もう嫌な人に決まってるんです
イメージを 一旦イメージ作ったら
いつまでもそのイメージで見る
見られる側がどんなことをあろうとも
それは構いなしでしょうに
我々の生き方は そこでたまに違う現象を見られると
認めたくないんですね
例えば嫌な人やと決めた人が
すごくいい人やという情報が入ったら
あれ これおかしいよと
それを否定しようとしてるわけです
例えばタレントさんの世界ですごい可愛いと決めた人が
どこかに相手がさ 見つかってあっちこち歩いてるんだと
デートしてるなと思ったら
それを否定しようとする
そんな感じで もう自分で決めたイメージで
で 生きてるんだから 世界みんな同じことなんです
ですから そこは理解できないと思ったら
なんのことなく ものすごい大きく大きく世の中見ると
人間っていうのはそういう働きだと見られるはずなんです
なぜならば 瞬間のレベルでもこういう風に働いているんだから
今説明したのは一秒間の一億分の瞬間の出来事なんです
この一秒の一億分の瞬間の出来事も
そういう風にも一旦イメージ作った
作ったイメージでいってしまった
終わります だから 見た対象の本当の状況についてはもうお構いなしと
だからもう自分勝手であって
わがままであって だからもう完全に愚か者であるという仏教の用語が出てくるんですね
ものすごいもう嫌な愚か者ですよ
みんな それはある個人を否定しているわけじゃなくて
この存在のプロセスを見てお釈迦様が使っている言葉なんですね
愚か者だと人に向かって言っちゃうと
その人を非常に批判したことになるでしょう
別に個人に対して別にお釈迦様にどうしたこともないし
関係ないし 恨みも何もあるわけじゃないんです
それは個人に言ってるわけじゃなくて
生命に向かって言っていることなんです
生命はそういう風に我儘好き勝手にできているんだと
ですから この心の 何と言いますか
余裕ある心で物事を見なさいと
人が悪いことをするんだからといって
嫌な人だ 見たくもないんだ
その人を破門しよう 差別しようとかね
そういう激しく この善のために
正義のために戦ってやろうではないかとかね
あれも無知そのものなんです
人が悪事したってしょうがないでしょ
その人がそういうふうにできているんだから
正義のために戦うという連中が完璧に正義の味方を持ってますかね
そうじゃないでしょうに
その連中にも嫌なものは壊してやろうという気持ちはまるっきりあるんだから
それで他の人が嫌なものを壊しちゃうと
あの人を殺してやりましょうと言って
正義のためにだと思っても行っちゃうんだよね
その時も見られるのは
すごいバカバカらしい現象なんで
例えばあるグループがある行為をいい行為だと決める
それで違うグループが違う行為はいい行為だと決める
そのグループから見れば
それはけしからんだと
それであいつらは良くないんだと
悪人たちだと なぜならば我々は決まってる行為は我々のある評価基準ですか
それは認めてないんだと
だから殺してやりましょう
我々こそ正義の味方だと
どっちでは正義の味方がいるわけじゃないんです
悪人を倒そうとしている人も
悪を起こしている人とみんな同じことをやってるんです
だからそういうのは お釈迦様はずっと教えたかったことなんですね
だから 大きな心で余裕を持って
世の中を無執着の心で観察してみなさいと
そうすると真理見えるですよと
例えば 人が悪人やということを我々決めちゃっても
ある瞬間で悪人なんですけど
次の瞬間で違うでしょうに
ですから判断するならば
その人の寿命は全部計算してシール貼った方がいいのに
例えば歳まで生きてた人がいて
もう歳までちゃんと生きていたならば
ちゃんと勉強して結婚して仕事を子ども育て
もう立派にいたんだと
それで歳でまあなんとかあって人を殺しちゃったと
そこで裁判もあって いろんなこと歳でその人はまあ処刑になっちゃったんだと
我々 あいつは犯罪者だ
殺人だ 悪人だと決める
たった瞬間でしたことだけでしょうに
その人に判決するならば
その人は 1 日1日1日どのように生きていたんですかと計算するべきでしょうに
そうしたら何の判断もできないはずでしょう
人間はそうじゃない たった一つの出来事を見て
それでも全部 ラベルを貼ってしまう
ですから この物事 世の中の物事は変化して
いつでもプロセスなんですね
ある個体したものはない
人間も何者でも変化のプロセスであって
そのプロセスで目に映った場面だけをとって
その場面で判断決めちゃって
イメージを作って それで我々の心が動くんです
それから自分たちの主観的な判断で世の中を見てみようと思っちゃう
それで哲学も作る 宗教も作る
全部 何の意味もないくだらないゴミだけなんですね
だから人の哲学でも何でも厳密に見なくちゃいけないんですね
仏教のこの教えはちゃんと世の中のものは見える
理解できるはずなんです
ある哲学者の哲学のテキストを読んだとしても
その人はすべての過程を見て
判断しているか ある現象にとどまってやってるかというのはすぐ見えるでしょうに
その目で見えると そうすると勉強もものすごい
今の人々よりはものすごい強烈な速さで勉強できるんです
ということで 仏教の法則を知っていると
もう他の知識は入れなくなっちゃうし
他の知識を得ようとしちゃったらもう何のことなく簡単に得ることもできるんですね
即行心から我々に教えてくれるのはそういう師匠なんです
一旦感情が生まれたら
それで回も同じことを繰り返す
この七回の即行心の働き
次に説明しますけど そのそれもこの走る働きだから
一番目の即行心っていうのは走り始めただけ
二番目はもう走っている
三番目はさらに速く走っている
四 五はもうピークになって走って
五で遅くなって 六で遅くなって
七で遅くなって終わると
ストップ そこにもあのサイクルがあるんです
あの生まれて大きくなって小さくなっていくサイクルがそこにもあるんです
ですから カルマが起こるのは
この七つの心でカルマを作るんですね
そこで一番目のカルマは弱い
当然二 三 五 六までは強いカルマとして
七番目のカルマはまだすごい
もう死んじゃうんだから
心それから で そこであのカルマ論に入ったらそこら辺説明しますけど
あの今覚えておいた方がその時簡単だから言いますけど
私たちは何かをしたとする
何か行為をしたとする
そうすると即行心は七つ生まれる
七つもカルマなんです
業なんです 業だから結果が得るはずなんです
そこで一番はすごく弱いんだから
結果は得るならば今世で得るんです
来世までそのエネルギーは持たないんです
二番目から六番目までは結構力あります
ですから 今世で結果が得られなかったら
来世でも次の生でもいつか結果出すんです
そこで七番目はまた弱い
弱いんだけど 一番目より強い
走ってきて止まる瞬間だから
走り始めてる瞬間よりは力強い
ですから 二番七番目の即行心が結果出す場合は
二回目まで生まれて次の生まれ変わりじゃなくて
死んで次の生まれ変わりで結果出すことは可能なんです
三回目はダメなんです
三回生まれ変わっちゃって
四回生まれ変わっちゃうと
七番目の即行心はもう働かない
力が弱いんですから カルマは消えるんです
人間 このあまりカルマなんか気にしないのは
悪いことをしてもすぐ目の前で結果が出ないだからなんです
すぐ目の前で結果が出るんだったら
誰も悪いことしないんです
人を殺した瞬間に 自分もその瞬間でひどい病気になって
何か痙攣を起こしたり
そのまま心臓発作で死ぬという現象が世の中であるならば
どんな人も人を殺せませんよ
例えばいろんなもう会社のお金を横領したり
いろんな悪いことを賄賂を取ったりしちゃうと
賄賂を取ってすぐ自分の財産がどんどんどんどん消えていっちゃうならば
こちらで賄賂を取ってうちに電話した瞬間に家が火事になったよと
というふうな速さで結果が出るならば
世の中で誰一人も賄賂を取ろうとはしないでしょう
でも残念ながらそうはないんですね
なぜならば 今世で受けるカルマが一番目の即行心なんです
すごく弱いんです もし今世で色んな工夫をしてからくりをして生きているならば
そのカルマの結果が出てこない
例えば法律の人だって
例えば殺人をしたんだと
その人はもう何とかしてどこかへ逃げちゃったりして
で 二十年で時効ですか
殺人は日本だったら十年
二十年 え？あ 十五年 十五年時効だとね
こちらでこちらの法律で決めてますから
で 殺人には時効 アメリカだったら時効はないんですけどね
で 自分の国はもしかすると二十年だと思いますけど
そのその国によっていろいろありますけど
日本だったら十五年で時効でしょう
そこで十五年間あちこち外国行ったりとかね
もういろんなことをやっていて
十五年経ってところ帰ったらどうしようもないんですね
もう逃げちゃったんだから
ですから そういう何とかして今世のカルマがカルマから逃げられる可能性もありますね
カルマから逃げられませんだけど
大体逃げられる可能性あります
他のカルマを受けているんだったらもう場もないしね
ですからカルマは一部は消えるんですが
消える可能性あるのはこの 1番目と 7番目
で  2番目から 6番目までは消えません
ずっと残るんです じゃあ次にまた 16セッスナと 17セッスナ
また残ってるんですね
16 17 というのはカショエンといって
このタダーランマの心が生まれるんです
タダーランマの心っていうのは
また成熟心なんですね
カルマの結果 行為の結果
それは二つでなきゃダメなんです
一瞬の心で味わうことはできない
だからこの心は 2つ生まれる
だから自分がやったことのなんとなく味わいですね
これはどういう意味かというと
これまた我々の日常生活から考えちゃうと分かりやすいんです
例えば私たちは何かするとする
そのしたことは終わったらほんの瞬間何もしないでいるんですね
で なんかもう大変何かもう神経質になって
何か大きな仕事をしちゃうと
仕事をやってやってやってもうもう終わったと終わった瞬間にホッとちょっとぼけーっとしてる瞬間があるんですね
次の仕事に行く前に あれでやっと終わったという味なんですね
いつでもそれあるんです
掃除していたんだと 掃除してしてして終わったら終わった
それからなんですよ 掃除機を片付けようとか出てくるのは
私の場合はその時間 たまにすごい長くなっちゃうんで
掃除機をして次の日までそのまま
コンセントさしたままで
まあ普通はそうじゃない
一応掃除機やって終わった瞬間でサッと閉めて
またそれを置いて また次の仕事に走ってとか
そういう風に人は動かないんです
一つの仕事終わって瞬間
ちょっとホッとして次の仕事に行くんです
あれはただ乱舞的な働きなんです
ですから そんなに分かりにくいことでもないんです
味わうと言ったっても
そんな味わうというよりは
ちょっとホッとする瞬間みたいなものなんですね
じゃあその一行目で説明したのは
この物質が生まれた瞬間で目に触れた場合なんですね
その時でも 我々は物質の大体五番目のセッツナで知るだけで
六番目 八番目 十四番目とか知るわけじゃない
それで心はもう勝手に回転している時だけ
じゃあ次に 大初縁に戻りますが
大初縁では二つありますね
チッタ・ヴィッティが
二つの差はこの目に触れた触れた瞬間の差なんですね
一番目では目に触れたのは何番目でしたっけ
三番目でですね 物質の物質は三歳の時目に触れたと
二番目は物質は四歳の時目に触れたと
だから動揺心生まれてるんだから動揺心で決めるんですね
ですから 五門因縁生まれるのは五番目のセッツナか六番目のセッツナですね
そこで五識が生まれるのは六番目か七番目になっちゃうんですね
ですから マハンターラマ大初縁の場合は
ものを見られるのはそのものの六番目のセッツナで
あるいは七番目のセッツナでそのものを見られる
そうすると順番で動揺心と水道心が生まれて即行心が生まれる
そこであの 十六セッツナで即行心が終わっちゃうでしょ
また一セッツナしか物質には寿命がない
だからほっとする時間がなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 可笑縁は生まれません
可笑縁じゃなくて可笑縁ですね
タダーラマナが生まれません
その代わりに心はウブンに戻るんです
三行目で書いてるものも同じなんですね
で 十七セッツナではまた即行心頑張ってるんですね
それは七回確実に生まれるんだから
で 可笑縁には時間がない
ですから このマハンターラマ大初縁時の差は可笑縁ないこと
それだけ そこで現れたもののどんな瞬間に見るかというと
一番目では五番目のセッツナで見る
二番目では六番目のセッツナで見る
じゃあそれで初生縁の説明見ましょう
初生縁の場合はこの チッタ・ヴィッティが六つ書いてますけど
でも理屈はすごい単純なんですね
理屈を見るためにはこのウブン動揺心どこにあるかを見てください
一番目は五番目 で それ一つ一つ右にそろえるでしょ
二番目は六番目 三番目は七番目のセッツナ
四番目になると八番目のセッツナ
五番目になると九番目のセッツナ
六番目になると十番目のセッツナで動揺心が生まれる
ということは 初生縁というのは物質が生まれて
生まれてから五歳で認識し始めるか
六歳で認識し始めるか
七歳で あるいは八歳で
あるいは九か十歳で見るかっていうことなんですね
ものは目に触れると その触れたものが六刹那が経過している
七刹那が経過している
八刹那が経過している
九刹那が経過している
あるいは十刹那が経過している
そこまでは初生縁というんです
同様にその五識が生まれる刹那も変わるでしょう
五識が八番目の刹那か九番目の刹那か
十番目の刹那か 十一番目の刹那か
十二番目の刹那か 十三番目の刹那かなんですね
他のリストは全部同じなんですね
また初生縁の一を見ると
五識が生まれる 八番目の刹那で九番目の刹那でそれは領受する
受ける 十番目の刹那で推動する
十一番目で確定する 確定したら次に即行心でしょ
即行心のために七つないとダメなんですね
でもどれぐらい残ってますか？六つしか残ってないんですね
だから即行心は生まれなくなっちゃうんです
時間なくなっちゃうんです
見たものはその先に消えちゃうんです
それで確定はしたんだけど
即行心は生まれなくなる
いわゆるカルマは感情は生まれなくなっちゃうんですね
それで確定心だけ まあ二
三回 三回ぐらい こちら三回書いてますから
三回生まれて心はもう眠る心に戻っちゃう
御本心に戻ってしまっちゃう
ですから 初生縁のもう一つの特色は
あの なんですか ジャヴァナ
あるいは即行心は全くないこと
ですから 対象が生まれてほんのわずか経過しちゃったら
我々にそれについて判断は生まれませんね
どんなものかと 判断というよりは
カルマは生まれません
感情は生まれません 見た
それで終わっちゃうんです
あれはいいですよとぐらい明確に味わう時間はないんです
まああの この新幹線はね
強烈なスピードで走っていると見ると瞬時に消えちゃうでしょうに
で 上野駅で あるいは東京駅で止まっている時はずっともう嫌なほど見られるしね
だから見られる時間によって感情感覚の問題も
のぞみとかね 遠いところで遠く走っている時見るともうもうすぐ
一瞬にもう現れて消えちゃうんですね
その時すごい百六でも見えますけど
どこへ向かっていくかとか
もう何もほとんど見えない
ただもう という感じで
目に入ったものはもう寿命を取ってるんだからすぐ消えてしまうんですね
ということは 何か物質生まれて
その物質は八番目の刹那で見ようとすると
即興心生まれる暇がないということなんですね
だから我々は知ってる世界も本当に知ってると思ってるんだから
いろんなものを見て感じて
膨大な感情を持ってるでしょ
好き嫌いの感情やら膨大に人間感情体持ってますからね
それは大体見るもの聞くものの
もう五番目と六番目の刹那で受けたものなんです
八番目九番目十番目で受けた感情じゃないんです
そこら辺で複雑さはわかるでしょうね
今日は大変私に説明しやすいんですから
このチャートがありますから
このチャートから目を離さないで見て見て考えてください
まあこれはパーリ語で我々やっちゃうと
こんなでっかいチャートにならないんです
こんな小さいんです これ全部書いたって
ですから 1発で見られますけどね
こういう字しか書かないんです
ジャワ語の場合はじゃしか書かないんです
ですから それでまあ簡単に覚えられますけど
チャックヴィンヤーナの場合はチャしか書かないし
ソートヴィンヤーナの場合はソしか書かないし
バワンガチャルナ 遮断の場合はナしか書かない
ナと決まってるんです
あの科学のあれ あれみたいに
もう一応文字決まってるんです
ナ書けば我々はバワンガチャルマと読むんです
で 書いてあるとババンパッチェと遮断と読むんですね
だからもうティーナーダースとか
そういう風にすごい簡単にできちゃいますから
じゃあこちらも日本語になって漢字入れて
いろいろパーリ語を入れて
全部完璧な全ての言葉を入れているんだから
ちょっと大きく見えますけど
じゃあそれから我々に考えられる何かないでしょうかね
こういうこと考えられるでしょ
ものの五番目と六番目
ものの寿命は十七歳にしてみると
ものが存在して十七番分の五番目と十七の六番目の間で見ると
我々は思い存分そのものはあると
いいものだと 悪いものだと判断して感情を作る暇があるんですね
だから何か生まれる 生まれたものが六番五番目の刹那で
あるいは六番目の刹那で私たちは認識しちゃう
そうするとそのものについて好き嫌いの感情を作って
好意を作ったりして その余裕が時間の余裕があるんです
それで人間というのはありとあらゆる感情の塊なんですね
我々の生き方は全部感情で決まってるんです
理屈で決まってないんです
論理でまるで決まってない
好き嫌いで決まってるんです
タバコを吸う人はどんな理屈あったっても吸うんですから
だからそこで吸うか吸わないか判断っていうのは
自分の感情で好きか嫌いかと
肉食べたい人はいくら体に悪いと言ったっても食べるんだから
そこで判断するのは自分が好きか嫌いか
それだけのことなんですね
ですから 結局は人間は偉そうにこの理屈やら論理やら使うんだけど
それで生きるわけじゃないんです
それで生きようとすると
また変な病気になってしまっちゃうんですね
この間の講演である質問があったんですね
もう何でもこの人を触ることもできなくて
消毒剤でまで手を洗ったりするんだとかね
それはおそらくもう理屈っぽくて病気でしょうと思いますね
あるいは細菌のことを勉強したと
顕微鏡で細菌なんか見たんだと
あるいはそういう科学的な大学研究者とかね
そういう風になっちゃって
次ついに感情を忘れて理屈になってしまったと
それで理屈で考える その机の上っていうのは細菌だらけでしょうね
人の体での細菌だらけでしょうね
人をしゃべる空気っていうのは
また体の中の細菌だらけでしょうね
これで細菌だからっていう風に人がものすごく病気になってしまっちゃうんですね
握手もできなくなっちゃうんですね
人と それはもう理屈だけで言っちゃうと精神的な病気になってしまう
人は理屈で生きていないんです
感情で